absolutely stunning I love this can you
tell me a little secret about this
yeah these earrings are really expensive
and I'm worried I'm that's my main thing
but yeah it this dress is by us on her
wish Bulgari and then Jimmy Choos shades
do you have security nearby in case my
token there may be by offering some I'm
like just don't lose them that's my like
main thing that's going in my head
tonight huge congratulations your new
album is right around the corner I mean
at this point right now as an artist
wife are the emotions when it's so close
are you nervous are you excited you just
want to get it out there for the fan
it's trying to fall two feet above
honestly I mean I still get nervous I
still get emotional I just have to go
with it feel my feelings kind of like
therapy
and it's really much kind of like to go
out on the road it is stuff it's like
you leaving your compass a long time
it's you know it's constant it's not
funny so I'd like to stay focused one
thing that I love about you so much is
that you are such a pillar for female
empowerment and I notice on your Twitter
you have support for normani Lana Del
Rey and so many others why is that so
important right now for women to support
women it is always important for women
to support women I think especially in
music you know we're all in different
lanes doing things differently and I
don't think ever has to be able to share
this you know I love showing the love
for people who admire them